can I sail through the change in heaven
is still one of my really good friends
Jenna
amber Chris after nya's Glee family
stood on the shores of Lake Piru to say
goodbye the tight-knit cast took to
social media to pay tribute umber Riley
posting this now heartbreaking video
with Naya and her son Josie captioned I
love you I miss you know that your
family will never have to worry about
anything
many former cast members sent
condolences to little Josie promising to
teach him about his incredible mom
authorities say Maya's last moments were
likely spent saving the four-year-olds
life she mustered enough energy to get
her son back onto the boat but not
enough to save her son
[Music]
yesterday expected mom Leah Michelle
posted pics of the two people she lost
on the same day seven years apart Anaya
and Cory Monteith kevin mchale tweeted
you'd be hard-pressed to convince me
that Corey didn't help find our girl
today Niall was grateful to have made an
impact on Glee and today the show's
co-creators honored her announcing they
are quote currently in the process of
creating a college fund for the
beautiful son Niall of most of all the
close bonds his mom formed will never be
broken it's like going to work every
single day was like 12 her best friends
you
[Music]